you
[Music]
thanks for coming I'm very happy to
introduce our Frank Wong from MIT
he's a piece teacher at MIT were is
advised by Nikolayevich and James
Mickens Frank works at the intersection
of systems and applied cryptography and
today is going to be telling us about
his dissertation work on predicting
privacy in web services Thanks hi Ron
I'm Frank and I'm a PhD student MIT
csail and today I'm going to talk about
some of my PhD research on building
systems that protect sensitive user data
and web services so whenever users
interact with web services like Google
Facebook or Yelp they provide their data
this data is important and valuable both
for the web service and the user and the
user is willing to provide her data
because she obtains valley from it for
example when a user provides her Fitbit
data she can track her health and
exercise as well as compare against
other users
I mean similar a user provides her data
to Facebook on so that she can more
easily learn about the social lives of
her friends and similarly share her
social life also you know buying things
off Amazon and thus giving your
preferences can lead to better product
recommendations so that's on that's on
the user side so on the on the other
side web services actually gain a lot of
value from user data as we know Facebook
has data on your preferences so you so
you can make more money off ads by
targeting them better Amazon can better
provide on product recommendations that
can lead to more purchases so however
there's a big security and privacy
problem web services often handle
sensitive user data in securely so at a
very high level this is how a web
service works a user submits a request
on her mobile device browser or some
some client to a service the service
processes that request which might
involve storing some user data or
performing some computation and returns
a response and so now service one has
some user data or has done some
computation and service one can then
also afford some of the data
- a second service or second service
might want to access data from the first
service so you know as you can see there
are many channels where user data can
leak or be compromised for example data
can leak on the user side through the
browser to an unauthorized application
not properly handling a query can also
leak private information about a user to
a service all unauthorized services can
also attempt to access the data and the
data can leak from the services database
and kind of the list goes on and you
know this happens many times because Web
Services often lacked cryptographically
secure mechanisms to protect private
user data and so kind of my research is
very focused on solving these types of
problems more more broadly it is on
building practical secure mechanisms to
protect sensitive user data in
large-scale web services and so
naturally much of my work lies at the
intersection of systems and cryptography
because as I'll show in the next slide
in most of my research I apply crypto
tools to build systems that help prevent
these data leaks and so on this is
difficult for two main reasons in my
opinion first most of these at Grant's
crypto techniques are relatively new and
not well studied and second it's
difficult to apply these crypto
techniques in a practical way to achieve
the system's goals and so as a result I
spend a lot of time with cryptographers
and you know I'm excited to continue
these collaborations across these two
communities so recall the high level
representation of a user web service
interaction and so this is how my
research projects aim to prevent data
leaks in some of the channels and so
many of the projects apply crypto
techniques in a practical manner to
prevent these leaks so veil is the first
platform that allows users to provide
stronger privacy private browsing
semantics
it focuses on client-side data leakage
and it's based on the premise that
private browsing modes like incognito
mode are leaky and extremely difficult
to fix in the browser alone my next
project is splinter which allows for
private user queries to web services
like Yelp or Google Maps in a practical
way and my next few projects are more
focused on server-side leakage so cobweb
and riverbed solve the problem that the
privacy policies for data and its
derivatives are hard to enforce through
complex applications so we develop a
practical information flow control
system on to deal with this in modern
web services and finally sieve provides
cryptographically enforce accent control
for user data it's motivated by the fact
that no data is constantly shared
between applications and so for today's
talk I will focus on splinter which had
a strong collaboration between
cryptographers and systems researchers I
worked with chef Ian vanilla MIT for the
cryptography and matei for the system's
aspect and the reason I'm focusing on
this project is first it's very thought
was really exciting to take a relatively
recent cryptographic tool and build an
efficient end-to-end private query
system and second you know I enjoyed
getting to different groups of
researchers on together to work on a
project they typically would not work on
so the systems people did crypto work
and the crypto people did some systems
work and so you know with this
collaboration we're able to execute on
this project relatively quickly and
efficiently and so here's an outline for
the rest of my talk I'll talk about
splinter the motivation threat model how
we execute splinter queries and finally
the evaluation and some future work so
to kind of motivate Splinter or suppose
a user wants a query or database to
retrieve records or perform analytics
some examples of this include searching
for a pen
sure your pen hasn't been published
looking for stock prices medical
databases to find certain diseases or
doctors and Expedia to find a flight for
a trip these queries leak sensitive user
information for example searching for a
pen on an outside database can reveal
ideas in your invention and investors
Coria might indicate whether they plan
to buy or sell a stock even searching a
medical database to learn more about
diseases and doctors could reveal and
leak potential health problems and
finally you know Expedia could raise the
prices of frequently searched flights
and so one naive way to solve this
problem it's just for the user to
download the database from the service
and perform the queries locally on her
machine I mean however these databases
like Google Maps stocks and patents are
usually hundreds of megabytes and the
user has to read download any updates
which leads to a high communication cost
and that's especially problematic for
users on mobile phones and so this
brings up the question how do we build a
practical system that can help keep
users queries private so to accomplish
this with our system splinter we
consider a slightly modified setting
with more servers and replicated
databases more formally splinter has two
principles the user and multiple
autonomous providers and each provider
has a copy of the same public database
in clear-text
we assume at least one provider does not
collude with the others so on the web
many of these databases are publics it's
just OpenStreetMap stocks flights data
and you know for efficiency they're
already replicated across many providers
also unlike in the naive approach we we
push some computation to the providers
and you know so so what happens in
Splinter
so user split sir query into multiple
parts and sends them to the provider and
each provider processes its share of the
query on the database records and then
sends back a response and so the user
takes all the responses from the
providers and combines them to get the
result without the providers learning
the original query unless all the
providers collude
so in splinter our queries have low
communication cost computation and
number of round trips and this allows us
achieve more practical performance
compared to previous systems and to do
this we use a recent cryptographic
primitive function seeker sharing to
achieve this and I'll talk more about
how this works later in the talk yes yes
if you relax saying there's it's not
clear what this crypto primitive would
look like I mean I think you know you
can imagine like you know we explored
using kind of information theoretic
private information retrieval you know
that kind of has different models that
you know has assumes like a majority or
like a minority doesn't conclude a also
has models where no one does include but
I think you know function secret sharing
allows us to kind of like get a lot of
the like good communication cost and
expressiveness I mean there could be
kind of something in the middle I mean I
think that crypto technique just doesn't
exist yeah I mean something worth
looking into them like the theoretical
side cool so now I've given you an
overview of splinter
I want to more explicitly state our
threat model so the data on the
providers is not sensitive and in
clear-text
we assume the providers are passive
adversaries and try to learn the users
query and they don't tamper with the
query or the data and we also assume
that at least one provider does not
collude with the others
so the contributions of this work are
the following
splinter which is a private query system
for public databases that scales to
realistic applications we are the first
system that uses an extends function
secret sharing FSS with new protocols to
run complex private queries we we
develop optimizations to lower CPU and
communication costs and we evaluated our
system on realistic applications which
led to response times of less than 1.6
seconds for databases with millions of
records and we have to have up to an
order of magnitude fewer round-trip
times than prior systems that are based
on cryptographic techniques such as PIR
and garbled circuits so now I've given
you a motivation and threat model I'll
move on to how we actually apply FSS to
execute splinter queries so here's the
query format that we support we support
a subset of sequel specifically
projections limiting filters aggregates
and no joins we support queries in the
following format select multiple
aggregates or projections from a single
table where certain conditions hold and
group by or order by multiple
expressions with a specific limit it's
important to note that Splinter's goals
is to keep the sensitive information in
the condition private and shown by in
the red box with a lock and so a more
concrete example is you know if we were
to search for the top 10 cheapest
flights for a certain round on Expedia
this is kind of an example query would
run and the condition in route equals 5
which is just an encoding of the route
leaks information about the route we are
searching for and so you know we want to
hide the number 5 and so in the next
slide I'll show you what conditions
splinter supports and you know later
I'll show you how we execute this exact
query while hiding 5 and preserving
privacy so splinter supports three types
of conditions in the query filter the
following table is a
Portland because the algorithm that
splinter excuse for query aggregates
depends on the condition type and so the
three conditions are equality only
intervals and disjoint ORS the form of
the condition is in the right column he
represents the column name and CI can be
an equality or interval condition so
splinter is the first system to use
function secret sharing FSS as a
building block for private queries but
before we describe how to actually
actually execute these queries I'll
describe some of the important features
of FSS so the goal of FSS is to evaluate
a function in a distributed fashion
without the providers learning the
actual function and so how does this
happen in FSS so first a function is
divided into K shares on these shares
have the following properties each share
can be evaluated quickly the sum of the
shares evaluated on an input is equal to
the input evaluated on the original
function and given all but one chair
someone can't recover the original
function f so there are efficient
constructions for two cases first point
functions which is a function that
evaluates to 1 if X is a specific value
and 0 otherwise and for interval
functions is a function that evaluates
to 1 if X is between two numbers and 0
otherwise so as you can see kind of at a
very high level we want to transform the
query conditions into FSS supported
functions and execute them on the
database with specific protocols on top
of that to preserve privacy and you know
in the next few slides I will show I
will give you some specific examples how
we go about executing these queries so
to better understand how FSS works in
the context of splinter I'll start with
how we perform a count query and so
suppose you know we want to know the
number of flights for a certain route
for simplicity let's consider a subset
of a flight database with two columns
route and price each provider holds a
host a copy of this database
like like that and so suppose we want to
count the number of flights where the
route is five but we don't want the
provider to learn that we are querying
for route five and so for reference in
this specific it when we run this
specific query the answer to this
question is two and so how does splinter
perform this query well first we need a
function that evaluates to 1 if the
input is 5 and 0 otherwise
and then the user uses FSS to convert
this function into function shares for
the number of providers and in this
example on there are 2 providers some
important properties of the function
share is F 1 and F 2 or that F 1 of X
plus F 2 of X equals f of X and having
either f1 or f2 doesn't reveal any
information about the original F which
contains the user sensitive information
our value of five so each provider
applies its share to each route record
in the database and it's important to
note that the provider has to scan
through every entry in the database or
else we leak user information so here
are some examples of values
that'll be output by the function chair
all these operations are done modulo and
integer field but in this in our case we
use negatives for illustration purposes
and so each provider sums together the
outputs of the evaluated functions and
sends them back to the user in this case
one provider sums up 21 and sends back
twenty one and the other one sums up
negative 19 and sends back that back to
the user who then sums them together to
obtain the answer to our original query
and so why this is work recall that F 1
of X plus F 2 of X equals f of X this
means in our example given our function
f of X equals 1 if x equals 5 across
providers the values will sum to 1 if
the route is equal to 5 and since f of X
equals 0 if X is not 5
across providers the values will sum to
zero as the route is not 5 yes I mean
yeah so I mean what it outputs is
actually random so it can be zero I mean
it's it's module integer field so it's
kind of like no zero to kind of like n
minus one in like Ziya in the integer
field like a vintage field has like n
elements right and so it could be zero
to like n minus one I mean I use
negative numbers here just kind of like
make things easier but it's all bought
something so real numbers are a little
bit trickier like you have to kind of
convert them into kind of an integer
first or like you kind of have to hash
them in some way it FS s works best when
the kind of input is an actual integer I
mean real numbers you could kind of like
imagine ways to kind of map some real
numbers to integers potentially cool
great so now suppose that we want to
perform a sum query say because we want
to find the average price for a specific
route so how do we do this it's it's an
extension of count and so we want to use
the same set up except we we want to do
a sum price instead of count in the
sequel query on the providers we do the
same thing as count except in addition
to evaluating the function chair on each
route record we also multiply the output
of the function chair or the
corresponding price and because FSS is
an additive function this essentially
has the effect of scaling the matching
records by the price and then the
provider or each provider adds up all
the results sends them back to the user
who sums them up and gets the final
answer to our query
so now we've seen how to do two types of
additive queries count in some let's
look at how we do non-additive query min
with inequality only condition so
consider the same table as the count in
some query and now we want to find the
price of the cheapest flight with route
5 and hide 5 now we use the same
function as before generate shares and
send them to the provider
so using FSS is not enough to execute
this query in this particular case
because FSS is an additive function so
it's not clear how it's directly
compatible with non-additive queries
like men and so so how do we perform
this query so our observation is that
the provider can use the public
information in the user provided query
to form another query more specifically
in our example the provider performs
select min price group by route and this
query creates an intermediate table
which has the min price for each
distinct route and because this table is
created using a query based on public
information no sensitive user
information is leaked and computing this
table takes linear time then we do the
same thing as sum apply the function
shares to all the records in the route
column in the intermediate table and
multiplied the min price column with the
output of each function chair each
provider then adds up all these values
and sends the response back to the user
so now let's try to do a min query with
the different condition type intervals
so again you know using emphasize it's
not clear here because of the min
aggregate but now also the condition now
contains multiple values that we want to
match rather than a single value like
the quality only condition and so one
naive way to perform to perform this is
to just perform the previous protocol we
described on multiple values but that
doesn't scale well to larger interval
ranges because we now have to do many of
these round trips so how do we kind of
do this with a limited number of round
trips and so let's say we want to select
the minimum price of several similar
routes and so now I'll provide a
high-level overview of this protocol so
first each provider uses the public
information in the query and they
compute a sorted table T using the
sequel query select route price order by
route then the providers find the min
price on power of two intervals in the
sorted table T secured for illustration
purposes and simplicity we just show the
price column in our table of T so those
numbers just representing the price
column that correspond to the sordid
routes so you know for a sort of table
of eight values we create size two up to
size eight intervals and so for the size
two intervals you can see we just look
at neighboring pairs of values and T and
pick the minimum and then we we continue
this process up to size eight intervals
and so we have a small table but you can
kind of see how we can do this
iteratively for larger tables yes
other soul so our route numbers so we
sort this ahead of time so yeah so no so
we don't so this so this is so this is
just the price columns of the route is
kind of corresponds to this you're
rockin can be any range
okay so the video the end it'll be sort
of visit if the user doesn't know I
guess no so the user doesn't actually
know anything about it doesn't know
anything about this table now kind of
show so the next like half tells you I
what the server does to kind of like get
the right value so here like the the
routes can be kind of anything like you
know the routes can have big gaps or not
big gaps or can be close to each other I
mean it doesn't matter because we just
sort this ahead of time the server knows
we're doing a min with an interval query
and kind of performs this sorted we're
like caches it and so kind of like this
is kind of what the server does in the
first step is kind of create these size
up to size eight intervals and kind of
in the next slide I'll show you kind of
what the server does to kind of return
the values back to ya and I'll show you
the next one how can resolve a lot of
this you know this is a price of zero
that's because our galaxy's in this e is
an example yeah I mean I go orange free
sorry route yeah yeah what careful you
have only seven wrong what do you do
with the piece I mean yeah so if I only
have any I mean if there's kind of like
a gap here you kind of still create up
to size eight intervals you can still do
this and you know you just so here like
say we're missing
like let's say we're missing zero then
this would just be one right I mean we
kind of like to size it like that and so
I mean it's definitely easier if its
power of two but you can kind of imagine
if it goes out here like we want to do
it to the next so if there are nine
there will be like up to like slide 16
so yeah then the algorithm proceeds in
two rounds so in the first round the
user wants to find the maximum and
minimum indices in the price column
where the route is between 1 and 5 in
this particular example and this
requires a cube parallel FSS point
function queries and so for this example
we find out that you know the min and
Max database indices for those specific
routes are say 3 & 6 and so in the next
round the client selects at most two
intervals of each size to cover the
target argot interval and returns a
result and in this case we select two
intervals from the sorted table of T
marked in yellow and one from the site
like one from the size 2 interval marked
in yellow and and and to cover the
targeted interval 3 to 6 and then we
choose 2 and 0 from the sort of table T
so it's important to note that you know
we can't just query these three yellow
values directly if we do the adversary
will learn that we'll learn our interval
conditions so that's why we have to
issue FSS queries for each interval
table so that the server doesn't know
what we're searching for and so but the
nice thing is that we can just do this
in parallel
and so in the last few slides I showed
you how splinter can execute additive
aggregates like counting some and
non-additive aggregates like max min and
top K for equality only interval
conditions I won't have time to describe
how we do non aggregates with destroying
or conditions but at a very high level
we use a private Brian research and
sampling on top of FSS to handle these
queries so now I've talked to you about
the how we execute queries I'll show how
these queries perform so here are just
some information about the three
applications that we built on top of
splinter and their data sets such as
number of rows and sizes of evaluation
setup and it's important to note that we
use real datasets in these applications
the rod is so here I'll present the
sequel queries who perform on our case
study applications and our goal was to
test various types of splinter supported
queries on different data sets to show
splinters expressiveness so for Yelp we
evaluated three carries our first query
we counted the number of tyrants the
next query we executed for the top ten
Mexican restaurants near me and finally
we find the best restaurants from a
subset of categories so for flight
search we look for an average price
before between a source and destination
pair for a certain month and the top ten
cheapest flights for a source and
destination pair and for map routing we
find paths and nearest nodes so these
queries assume transitive reading which
is a map routing technique that's
compatible with Splinter but you know I
won't go into too much detail on how
that works exactly here so here is a
table that summarizes splinters
performance there are a few important
things to note we evaluate our system
using two and three
providers because the performance
especially the communication costs
differs based on the number of providers
so let's dive into the case studies with
Yelp you can see that these queries have
pretty sure response times the
communication costs are low
however with provided with three
providers we have slightly higher but
still reasonable communication costs
these costs are still lower than
downloading the whole database and one
thing to note is that the best rated
restaurant in the category subcategory
has 11 round trips and this is because
it requires a max query on a disjoint or
condition which uses this private binary
search algorithm that I didn't describe
but by ends up being log log n of round
trips where n is the size of the
database the patient cost o from 2 to 3
yeah so I'm the protocol for kind of
like dealing with the three and more
server um is different than the two
server so the two server has like a
slightly different like FSS protocol
like we didn't know modify any of the
FSS protocols but the two server one is
a little bit more efficient it's a
little bit slower actually in some cases
but the a31 it's kind of dependent on
kind of it just has more communication
because like the factor is different in
the in the protocol itself it's not much
I mean I guess in this case I mean it's
still pretty good I think like if you
look at the account for example it's
only like 30 kilobytes and so I but the
other one like do megabytes I'll only be
able to do it like 10 queries right so
it'll be roughly 23 megabytes which is
which was the size of the database yeah
by mean I mean like yeah but you know
there are updates like on the database
right answer or the updates have to be
wrapping transaction scope you kid up
like you have to do
global transaction is international
directory customs or not date yes or I
mean you don't have to do it across
everything I think you just want to so
here you just you know say we have 100
servers you'll need to pick three so
only those three have to be synced out
right and so like no maybe you have like
these mirror sites maybe you always tell
people like these three are synced up or
like these two are synced up and so like
it only has to be synced up between the
it's like as the size of the data
increases are you better sort of is your
slope better than downloading the
deities right so as as that increases
they're gonna think more and more time
to not look at it up is right okay so
that's gonna increase in some slope
which is probably you know where the
size of that base what is your slope as
you increase the size okay it doesn't
come off from the stable unfortunately
okay yeah it's a couple of for the
question so is this year what is the P
alone yup close what is the other one oh
it's just like you know the yelp
academic database is except I do this
what is another represented
representation of a real database I mean
it's it's we try to make it as close to
real data as possible but what like no
yo gave out is like what their database
was okay and then the second question is
how do you arrange for these multiple
providers like who do you see in the
real world being these providers yeah so
I think I think in the real world you
can imagine either someone volunteering
to kind of host some of this and then
you know Yelp kind of uploads that and
they kind of pay a fee or like you know
Yelp itself has like a private version
and then as a result they kind of host
these multiple databases that they
already have and you kind of pay Yelp to
kind of issue queries kind of like how a
lot of API is work now like when you
make API calls they charge you you can
imagine like making these types of API
calls to Yelp and you'll have charges
you but they're saying hey like you know
we're not collecting information but now
we need to run these servers now here
here like you pay for this
providing a service for a year but
wouldn't isn't that in conflict with a
non collision assumption because on the
one hand you are assuming that there is
sort of doctor yet because the other is
going to pay them to provide an API a
service on the other men you are
assuming non collusion right right I
mean I like clues in the sense I like
they're kind of like they're colluding
with each other kind of like observe
this right like so our substrate is like
someone will like be monitoring and like
sharing information so like I guess like
ideally you would have like you know two
or three different types of providers
like there will be multiple people who
host this like multiple API services
that like are independent or like
someone runs as a volunteer
okay kind of a related question yeah so
for the FSA ask people who ruled
whenever the paper what scenarios did
they use yeah I mean I think they were
using the original I think they're kind
of looking at two things so like they
were originally looking at like a
traditional like PIR kind of situation
where you know now instead of looking
for an index we can kind of like you
know we don't have to index things ahead
of time we can just like match a record
directly and they were also kind of
thinking about like you know situations
where you want to kind of compute like a
distributed function so I think they
were kind of trying to think of it like
a multi-party computation sense or kind
of a you know you know maybe I just want
to like form out kind of like a
computation but they weren't very
specific I think a lot of it was you
know they were inspired by kind of PIR I
mean secret sharing and kind of like
seeing like you know can we get better
performance by looking at that so and
why was joint hard for your team to
support sorry so you said you don't
support Julie yeah so it's not clear how
you do emphasis with your I mean you can
kind of like think about like joining
having materialized views and joining a
lot of databases like we can support
that in that way but we don't kind of
like have a very clean way to kind of
support that Jordan
I think you have I imagine like there
you can use some form of like private
set intersection and kind of like work
with emphasis and that but it wasn't
kind of clear to us immediately how to
do that join
and so for flies to me we have a much
larger database to kind of find the top
10 cheapest flights between two
destinations takes less than 40
milliseconds to do average monthly price
or top 10 cheapest flights only took a
few kilobytes in terms of communication
and we can do map routing in about 1.2
seconds and now all these queries have
less than 1.6 seconds in response time
on a real network and many queries can
be run in hundreds of milliseconds and
so most queries have one to two round
trips and all queries had communication
much smaller than the size of the
database and so I mean although we're
slower than running the queries natively
splinter can perform common web
application queries very practically and
more practical in Prior systems and the
next slide I'll show you how splinter
compares to other schemes yeah so the
content Mexican restaurant opted to chew
his clients and this similar the cursor
yeah the quirks are similar so those
under the fly has a larger database and
Java swallowed in evasive but then the
communication Casta to the flight is are
much less than your case sorry I see
you're saying the communication for the
foil flight flight to talking to a
larger database with only four K at YK
all right so Mexico so I started all the
[Laughter]
yeah I mean I think in the in the top 10
so in the top 10
cheapest flight case like the flight
table like the the flight like record
itself records itself were smaller and
then like the records for the restaurant
were a bigger because the the records
for the restaurant so the flight we
actually returned numbers and the
restaurant actually returned strings and
so it's gonna be a little bit bigger
like it's a it's based on the kind of
specific record size so like you know
there's a big database but like the
record size vary and the record size is
for the Yelp was bigger than like the
individual like there are more records
in this like a lot more but each record
in individual
record sizes smaller no no you don't
need to return all of them but you need
to return a row of the database right
the row of the database like the
information in that database is bigger
which one has more roles can't go back
yeah the flight is a 16-time it's 30,000
more rules yeah but but its third times
more rows but it's only like 10 10x
bigger right but in terms of size so
that means right so like it has it has
30x more rows but it's only 10x bigger
bigger in in size like in megabytes
right and so each row is actually a much
smaller how like if you do kind of like
row per kilobyte or whatever or megabyte
and so you know when we return it we
have to return the whole row right we
want to return the whole row like
information the whole row
yes yeah it does it depends on so the
performance of FSS like how many times
you do emphasize that depends on like
the size of the domain of the input so
like you know the domain of X so if the
domain of X is like 32 like 32 bits its
you know you have to perform FSS like 32
times because it has a bit by bit
comparison so let's see so the so we're
not using all 64 cores and in in
everything but we use one core in
everything but the routing the routing
we use we use 64 cores did you try and
use the Mac circuit of course that's of
course a more coarse production stuff
respond specifically so it I did for the
other ones and it didn't change it
didn't change substantially and the
reason is so there's kind of like some
caching we do and if we use kind of like
if we so there's some caching we do
because like if you know the answer to
an FSS query so for example I do like on
FSS on like the number two like for
given query that will be the same answer
for every time like the output of that
will be the same every time so like the
caching I didn't get it to work kind of
across multiple cores I try to but it
seemed like the caching was like pretty
efficient and so if you use multiple
cores like the caching like they compete
for the cache but but it did the the map
router had you know we we use a cache
the cache hit was a lot less and so
that's why I think it worked better with
more coarse yeah
I mean we wanted to like have them run
like an unrealistic machine I think for
us like this routing we were saying like
hey like you know if we wanted to like
run it on like a machine that like an
actual provider would have like one I
missing those machines I mean they're
realistic but you know if I'm like if
I'm like a big web service or like I'm a
provider or ideally have multiple
machines I don't have like a machine
with like a single core right
and so look like why 64 that seems that
recruiting all right I mean it was a
little bit it was a little bit arbitrary
but we kind of wanted to find like a
like a beefy machine to see like you
know how it scales if certain things
would scale with more cores
so yeah but but most of these are
actually happening like one course
so so for four let's assume like within
one query cuz like if I do FSS like
let's say you know the record number is
five or something and so I have five
seven five and so when you apply FSS to
five it gives you kind of an output of
an integer and then and then that's the
same if you apply FSS to five again so
it's like deterministic across the query
that makes sense yeah no because like
it's for a given query emphasis on five
is the same but like a different query
it's different but you know no multiple
records could be like multiple bros
might have the same thing in like a
database and so we can just cash that
and you know you can kind of imagine
like four flights that could be like the
same destination pair might happen like
many times there's multiple flights
between two destination pairs you know
query is the over the free some the
database that was just having one entry
beach and then speech yeah right but we
don't know kind of like what the query
is ahead of time right and so which is
essentially doing the same thing but you
know more restrict what because you put
your query at this point you're going
through the database you saying well
we'll keep this evaluation as FSS for
him so that we give you the T in later
writing right and if you had that point
you know what these are
you can run through the database once in
like mini as my peanut schnapps that he
booked one evaluation for the fairness
of each possible feature
right it's like sending a fashion trend
I see so so you're saying that I find
know ahead of time what that FSS query
is like basic it I mean my
understandings you're right constructed
at Emory table it could some bean right
yeah he's saying if you're doing some we
could construct a temporary table of
something then this apply if I sell each
different like that right I mean yeah
you could I mean this yeah yeah you
could um well I mean I think like you
have to do this for all the variations
of the columns right like you know if
you do because like it if I do like a
some on the I got to do this for all
combinations of like key some right like
I I here in the example it's a little
bit simplistic because my table only has
two columns but I could have like
multiple columns and I have to do like
the sum for everything I mean I could I
could I mean just put more storage in
and I could speed it up like that that
is a possibility yeah but yeah but you'd
have to increase your storage I sub say
yeah yeah I mean I saw some of these
like you can imagine like for top ten
and stuff like that we improve you can
pre-compute like common ones you can
play some of these database common
database tricks to make this a little
bit faster like you know if you have a
lot of comments equal queries this
happens like an Oracle database or like
s AP database like you know if you see
queries are very common you can have
like pre computes and views to make it
go faster right like that's definitely
possible like here we just we just don't
assume that so
cool so we compare splinter to the
state-of-the-art system by olam ofen
which is most similar on to splinter in
terms of supported queries and for
similar queries and databases splinter
adds up to an order of magnitude lower
response times compared to omo fin and
the number of round trips for their
system is proportional to a log factor
of the database which is about 10 and
for splinter most queries only take a
constant number of round trips and takes
login only for a very select few and the
lower round trips is especially useful
in high latency networks where these
types of web applications are commonly
used yes so they're based on information
theoretic PIR and so you I didn't run
their code on my database so I kind of
compared kind of like in terms of round
trip times like in terms of like number
of round trips how many it would take
you like you write if they if I ran
their query how many would take and how
many round trips it would take like
that's kind of like easy to compute
based on their algorithm
okay so just an estimate based on the
round-trip time that you said assumed in
your yeah so these runs response times
are actually like them without any
network latency and so I mean I'm just
kind of showing you these numbers to
kind of see like you know the range is
like much different than the range here
that's the purpose of this slide because
the computation is heavy right like
you're using like right so I mean did
you come up with so yeah those the the
numbers so this the top number is out of
the paper like they're paper to kind of
like this it was like a similar-sized a
base and sam hi there i it was similar
and similar nikla conditions no dad no
networking dishes so I mean I think you
know for this this is kind of like you
know we're we didn't do like a very
direct comparison I mean these numbers
could be kind of like fudged a little
bit and like it would change if we
actually like when and perform what they
had but I think we're like the goal of
this was trying to just show you know
like for them they have to use like
information theoretic PA are like it's
it's a totally different model on the
kind of what we use I mean I think the
comparison is it it's not 100% fair like
I can admit that but kind of I'm just
giving you a sense of like you know like
this is what potential I mean I mean
sure I mean I think a lot of days like
we thought about like I mean it's it's
like a completely different model like
the kind of like we have much fewer
round trips than they do it's like how
do you you know we can kind of model
that to I mean I think those are all
like possible things
because they're justing yeah but they're
not really doing extras though because
they I mean they are doing X or s but
they have to do a lot of pre-computation
like on the demand
I'm computational news PR because they
only have this tool that allows them to
query for an index so they kind of have
to like do a lot more work so I mean how
you kind of like I think it's you know
we can kind of think of different models
and convincing models to kind of think
of it but this you know there's multiple
ways we can model it um but you know I
think just in general kind of like the
point of this yeah to give you like a
big sense I'm not claiming hey like you
know we like beat them by it so much but
I'm saying like then the numbers are so
different like the point is like the
numbers are so different right
that's that's only the kind of point I'm
trying to make with this line I did but
they didn't respond which is I think
maybe I think he had graduated a long
time ago and so this is like a like a
three or four year old paper at least
and so yeah yeah I mean IIIi didn't try
but I mean we could have tried yeah I
think they they use like when the yeah
one of these like ITP RPI are kind of
like libraries out there so
cool oh yeah I'm so there's been a bunch
of work on practical private query
systems and splinter is also related to
work on PIR systems and garbled circuits
but you know Spencer is more practical
compared to those other systems you know
the the practical private query systems
suffer from some combination of limited
functionality heavy leakage and bad
scaling in PIR a user can privately
query for a relaxed record over a record
at index I without the server's learning
the index or the response however not
much work has been done on building on
very practical PIR systems that can
perform realistic application queries
typically said the art PIR systems use
multi-party information direct prr from
performance reasons and even with that
these systems require many round-trips
high communication costs for the type of
queries that splinter supports but you
know because we use FSS we get around a
lot of these performance issues and you
know with information theoretic PIR they
all to get the performance they require
that no priors collude while in Splinter
we allow you know all but one to
conclude with each other there's
different PIR kind of scheme so like the
more efficient ones obviously like they
assumed none of the providers can
collude but you know there's a lot of so
information theoretic it's the very
common ones either like a minority or
like a slight majority collude or none
collude but you can also kind of imagine
information through a scheme or all but
one could also but you kind of get into
like heavier computation communication
costs and then you know computational
PIR is like kind of a different scheme
like that's like a trustless scheme
right and so and you know there are
their communication and computation
costs are much higher so is your
technique in some sense critical that's
a core like crypto building block out
so what what is the key when you compare
them that enables you to be better than
PIR yeah I mean I think I think the the
biggest difference between I mean I
think funny to your sharing is like just
very different because one it's like
it's not I think it's it's an expressive
PR or kind of like if you think of it
because you now you don't have don't
have to have an index you kind of can
match records you can do less than
greater then which is like actually not
possible in PIR directly like of course
you can play some tricks to make it work
and I think you know their information
to rec PR you know they do X ORS and so
they kind of require multiple servers
it's a different model but in
computational PIR you have to use like
public key cryptography and you know we
use one wave function so I think we kind
of stand in the middle between kind of
like in terms of kind of assumptions why
is between like cryptographic
assumptions between information
theoretic and computational PIR so I
think it's kind of it's just a different
model I think it it's hard to directly
compare because they all provide
different features but I think you know
the expressiveness is a very key
features i and the expressiveness with
the kind of like what we call any trust
or like one non colluding server
assumption it's like I think you know
very strong I'm in an interesting kind
of like model to look at using three
servers over two servers is that it's
harder for three servers to cause any
goal commute yeah so in that case like
you know two servers can be malicious I
think the clear thing is a main thing
and second it's a little bit faster for
like larger databases like just because
the the scheme is a little bit different
but the disadvantage with why it's a
little bit faster obvious like now you
have more communication costs because I
mean just current FSS with three or more
parties require like there's the factor
depends on the number of parties and
we're in two server doesn't so it's just
kind of how the scheme works I mean I
think you know it's very new scheme I
think there's a lot of work that kind of
needs to be that both on that side and
kind of like thinking more about what's
going on
yeah and so kind of continued garbled
circuits they're a secure of computation
tool allows two parties to privately
evaluate a function but using this tool
has very high computation and
communication cost in our specific
setting and so to kind of conclude the
splinter part of the talk so current web
services leak sensitive information to
user queries I present to you splinter
which is the first system that uses a
neck sense have assessed with new
protocols to efficiently protect these
queries on splinter enabled versions of
realistic applications are fast and
secure and so kind of now I've talked to
you about splinter I'll talk to you a
little bit about future work yeah so we
do have in our paper so we kind of like
look at Amazon costs so like you know
one query if it's not an Apps query it's
a regular it cost about point I think
zero one sense it's like less than a
cent in terms of computational cost in
terms like if you kind of do like a time
and match
I mean this was kind of we did this a
lot of this research before the times of
like serverless and so like I think
you've you run out of service it could
be much cheaper but we kind of assumed
like a web server how much time of that
web server it was taking it was kind of
it was less than it's like point zero
one cents very fast I think it's hard to
really make that comparison because yeah
about probably three orders of magnitude
because the reason is because databases
like we can't do a lot of the
traditional tricks that a database can
so like a like a database is like
heavily engineered like they have like
scope of everything they can do query
planning that we cannot they can have
optimizer rows and they've had hundreds
of engineers work on it like you know
optimize like the crap out of like a
database right and so I and they're very
cognizant performance etc so drives so
yeah sure caching them further I mean we
do some caching but like area I'm
friendly you know like you have to pay
storage costs
I mean I think it's because like yeah
that's important it's like insecurity
like you have security you don't have a
view of certain amounts of information
about guys yeah like it like in yeah in
the sequel database if you see every if
you know everything you can I like kind
of like plan for it right so yeah so
here some of my um kind of fall one work
so you know Splinter has reduced
overhead for private carries by
leveraging FSS but you know it's really
only at the beginning I think some of
you guys brought up some I kind of
follow on work or some work interesting
work that needs to be done you know the
amount of data in these web services is
only growing and you know it's users
express more expect more expressive
queries and so you know it's not clear
how we can scale to billions or
trillions of records with this scheme
how would you have more expressive
queries like joins and knots how we
improve the efficiency for really four
or more servers like I said for two or
three it's pretty efficient starting
from four doesn't scale as well because
the FSS technique does not scale as well
past four servers and so you know some
future directions we've been thinking
about and trying to make more progress
on it's like how can we do some four PIR
or FSS with pre-processing so we don't
have to look through the whole database
I'm every single time so I think that
helps on the billions of trillions of
records part like how can we design a
more expressive FSS to solve the
expressive queries part you know maybe
this just requires new cryptographic
tools for systems or new cryptographic
PR FSS scheme like schemes and so on a
related topic you know PIR and FSS and
multi-party computation MPC have pretty
strong connections and in FSS we wanted
to hide the function but the input was
public however in MPC is a reverse
problem we want to hide the input but
the function is public and so more
concretely we have four values x1
through x4 and we want to compute a
known function on it however the
server's want to know the result of the
function but don't want to reveal their
respective inputs to the other servers
and so so you know why is this useful
organisations are storing more and more
data and
cloud and data is becoming more
digitized however many times
organizations might want to keep their
data proprietary but might be willing to
compute a shared function or selectively
store data and so for example on
patients might one might visit different
hospitals for various conditions as a
result not one Hospital has a complete
view of the patient's health so you
imagine this for millions of patients
similarly many patients might have a
similar condition but a single hospital
will only have a sparse data set to do
research on this and but across many
hospitals there could be a richer data
set and so in the current world medical
researchers can be missing key insights
because the data is so fragmented or but
with MPC you have a way to share and
analyze this data in a secure way
and so the reason MPC is not used
frequently in practice is because of
poor performance both in computation and
bandwidth so an interesting future
direction is to make garbled circuit
systems more efficient some recent work
out of Berkeley has shown that garbled
circuits can be used some somewhat
practically in systems but they have
limited functionality the goal is to
kind of expand the function of these
garbled circuit systems and make them
more practical similarly there's a
related FSS technique called home
morphic secret sharing which kind of
reverses this and so for them like the
function is public but the input is
private also and they do that for
branching programs and so but you know
you can kind of like imagine it being
more expressive with more functionality
also and you know another extension for
MPC is to find ways to maybe do MPC on
graphs more efficiently which is a
common data structure commonly in
security as kind of people try to
contextualize and respond to threats and
so I'm I'm excited kind of to continue
collaborating with both cryptographers
and systems researchers to solve these
problems and find new systems
applications for a lot of these
cryptographic tools and so you know I
want to thank all my wonderful
collaborators that's made my PhD
possible and so there are folks from
systems and cryptography and so I've
also had a lot of wonderful discussions
with companies like Akamai rapid7 and
purr
to kind of help me identify and motivate
a lot of these research problems so yeah
thanks witches now if if this technology
is widely used then the provider cannot
learn some useful please like a round
number five is hot or Thai restaurant is
popular have you thought about any
technology that still allows to do some
statistical yeah I mean I think um I
think it's hard within this model where
it's its goal is to kind of like hide
kind of this information if you have no
information it's hard to kind of like do
some of this statistical learning I mean
I think you can imagine kind of a world
where someone kind of like does these
aggregates kind of like independently
like for example like you know either
anonymously or kind of like some third
party does some aggregation like using
like multi-party computation or kind of
something like that but yeah I think
that's like a separate problem and we're
like you know I have this you have to
some you can't learn it from the query
directly like there's be some separate
system that's kind of collecting a lot
of this information and kind of
aggregating it yeah I think here we're
trying to really provide aggregates from
happening but finally I purchase a
ticket to that information war still can
be used yes to marketing or just vice
yeah I mean in that case it would be but
you kind of prevent the problem where
the multiple people look for a certain
flight and they raise the price as a
result yeah but yeah if you purchased a
flight ticket sure